allez assez parlé du covid on va passer
aux infos du jour on commence avec ces
infos
[Rires]
on va revenir sur les propos de morial
Robin dans quelle époque sur France 2
Sami niçois l'humoriste a déclaré que si
elle ne faisait pas de cinéma c'est
parce qu'elle avait toujours assumé son
homosexualité regardez je suis la seule
actrice au monde à dire son
homosexualité au monde vous êtes la
seule actrice je connais les acteurs
homo français il se taisent mais bien
sûr sinon le remettra plus jamais une
femme dans les bras si on est homosexuel
on n'est pas désirable on n'est pas
pénétrable si vous êtes vieille vous
n'êtes plus pénétré si vous êtes moches
vous n'êtes plus pénétrer je dis un mot
c'est fou viens comprendre de quoi c'est
très très fort des hommes qui pénètrent
les femmes sur les papes pénétrable on
est on vaut rien il faut dire aux jeunes
comédiens et comédiennes de 13 14 15 16
17 ans faut leur dire c'est pas la peine
c'est pas la peine de quoi qu'on
comprenne pas la peine qu'il fasse ce
métier travail
si vous êtes homosexuel ne faites pas
positionnez-vous
ou monter ce que j'ai vécu alors oui
alors
je veux des gens qui sont pas d'accord
parce que pour écouter gilbertez voilà
non c'est bon je veux des gens qui ne
sont pas d'accord qui ont les
coordonnées
parce que ça fait des années qu'elle
veut faire du cinéma ça fait des années
que le cinéma lui ferme ses portes c'est
pas vrai alors c'est pas vrai
elle a fait les visiteurs quand elle est
visiteurs après elle a pas fait tous les
films qu'elle voulait faire avec My Way
comme ça
depuis qu'elle arrête pas de nous dire
je veux faire du cinéma je veux faire
cinéma alors sur les planches elle est
incroyable en hauteur en autrice pour
faire le rire les gens elle est
incroyable c'est la meilleure comédienne
a été très forte au cinéma
Jacqueline ça va avec Olivier Marchal
pas de problème mais faut pouvoir
arrêter de tout le temps trouver des
causes parce qu'elles parce qu'on la
prend pas pour le cinéma peut-être qu'on
la prend pas parce que c'est le physique
qui va pas peut-être que le cinéma ne
veut pas de son physique peut-être que
c'est ça aussi c'est pas forcément sa
sexualité mais moi je pense que
elle parle d'un truc qui est à mon avis
exact c'est à dire qu'il y a une vraie
homophobie dans certains pans de la
société française mais je pense que dans
son métier à elle je pense qu'elle n'a
pas elle était victime de ça par rapport
à son identité sexuelle elle a voulu
saoûter par exemple quand elle dit qu'il
y a plein de comédiens qui sautent pas
pour pouvoir travailler et pour pouvoir
être désirable je pense qu'elle a raison
effectivement tout le monde le sait tout
le monde le dit dans les coulisses tel
chanteur et homosexuel il va pas le dire
non mais si ça existe aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je suis pas sûr que voilà
que ce soit aussi criant que ça mais je
me lance pas que ce soit à cause de son
identité
je pense que en fait elle est tellement
il y a plein d'humoristes parce que
vraiment
Michel Bernier exactement
je suis désolé oui Patricia
le problème principal c'est la France
qui nous met dans des cases et quand on
fait une activité bon on peut pas en
faire une autre tout simplement je suis
un peu plus là
il fait pas 40 films désolé Rachel parce
que
c'est bien là où elle a raison c'est
qu'il y a un manque de prise de risque
entre guillemets parce qu'effectivement
peut-être que les scénaristes imaginent
que le public c'est-à-dire nous on n'est
pas assez ouvert on n'est pas assez
malin entre guillemets pour accepter que
un homosexuel ou une homosexuel prenne
un partenaire de du sexe opposé dans les
bras mais ça soit crédible à outre son
homosexualité alors qu'il ne l'est pas
enfin s'il était il était homosexuel
est-ce qu'il serait le héros de Mission
Impossible ou si Daniel Craig était
homosexuel je ne le crois pas parce que
je pense évidemment le public serait
malgré tout un peu encore sur la
défensive les producteurs on dirait non
jamais de la vie on veut revenir sur une
deuxième info c'était hier soir dans
Capital sur M6 une productrice de pâte
artisanale déclare qu'elle vend ses
pattes 9 euros le kilo 9 euros le kilo
les pâtes alors qu'un kilo de pâtes
classique ça coûte aujourd'hui en
dessous de 2 euros même avec l'inflation
on va regarder chez le Verdez cet été
outré elle fait ce qu'elle veut si on a
qui veulent acheter en fait
claire neurochine pas à fabriquer ses
pattes parfois pendant 7 heures
d'affilée et elle n'hésitera pas non
plus ensuite à faire payer le prix de
son travail la pâte non farcie c'est 2 €
à peu près 2 euros prix de revient pour
une revente à 9 euros du kilo 9 euros le
kilo c'est deux fois le prix vendu en
grande surface pour ces pâtes farcies
une recette comme ça le chèvre épaisseo
je la revente 33 euros du kilo c'est une
marge de fois 4 voilà jusqu'à 3,70 € les
100 g soit 37 euros le kilo c'est le
prix d'une côte de bœuf et la recette
est bonne ça fait un total de 1057 euros
j'ai dégagé à peu près 800 de marches
c'est ça c'est bien c'est un bon marché
alors s'il y en a qui veulent l'acheter
il y a deux problèmes à mon avis d'abord
je trouve ça bah ça fait une polémique
quand même d'abord je trouve ça parce
que vendre des pâtes à ce prix-là
excuse-moi excuse-moi il y a des patates
très cher
personne n'obligera t'engager Cyril très
franchement
cette même conversation concernant des
restaurants absolument ben c'est comme
si tu dis je ne comprends pas pourquoi
c'est si cher que dans un étoilé ou
c'est plus cher ou c'est moins cher dans
un bistrot on t'oblige à aller dans un
étoile va tu payes le prix de l'étoile
et bah là c'est pareil ce sont des pâtes
fraîches réalisées avec des marges
évidemment mais c'est ce qu'elle veut si
tu veux pas les acheter s'il n'y avait
que ça sur le marché et qu'on oblige le
consommateurs
à payer 9 euros
ça fait plaisir
[Rires]
la qualité monstre du travail une
entrepreneur qui se lève le matin qui
fait tous ces produits regarde la tête
qu'elle a la pauvre elle est elle est
bonne
je te jure et moi je pense même pour moi
9 euros c'est pas très cher elle aurait
dû les mettre à 25 et crois-moi les gens
ils achètent et quand c'est cher tu es
attiré je t'ai déjà vu dans des
restaurants le druide t'inquiète pas
[Applaudissements]
de Gilles Verdez et en fait une
dictation
même prix 33
pour sa transparence bravo quand tu
achète un sac à ta à ton épouse
à 100 €, il y a des patates
laissez-moi lui parler Gilles tu
confonds une fois de plus tout tu es de
plus en plus excuse-moi
tu sais que c'est incroyable je sais pas
ce qui se passe en ce moment je sais pas
ce que tu as fait cet été mais tu
arrives encore plus teubé que avant la
avant la rentrée non mais je te le dis
je t'aime beaucoup j'ai perdu les
bagages mon avion était annulé ma
voiture
je sais pas où hein parce que elle t'a
pas demandé de toute façon elle fait ce
qu'elle veut si elle veut mais regarde
de toute façon c'est avant de les pâtes
9 € le kilo et que ça marche pas
le prix deux fois plus sur le
supermarché bien sûr pas 450 1 kg de
pâtes chez M6 il faut qu'ils aillent en
cours 50 le kilote pas merci
ne puissent plus se nourrir dans les
supers appartements et il y a une
proposition d'Olivia Grégoire Olivia
Grégoire qui a fait une proposition
ministre délégué pour tenter d'aider les
Français à vaincre l'inflation il faut
réapprendre à cuisiner
merci
merci beaucoup c'est marrant et en plus
en plus je l'aime bien Olivia bon alors
voilà on a c'était une base on n'a pas
tout pris mais voilà ce qu'elle a dit et
on va réapprendre à cuisiner notamment à
l'école ah on va parler de cette info
alors la raison c'est une info numéro 1
du jour
elle a raison parce que en fait elle met
le doigt sur le problème des plats
préparés elle met le doigt où elle veut
oui la problématique des plats préparés
c'est ce qui coûte cher c'est c'est gras
c'est mal foutu et ça on doit dire aux
gens que faire de la nourriture chez eux
en s'appuyant sur des marchés fin de
marché excuse-moi juste juste je peux
dire un truc moins cher je peux te dire
un truc je peux te dire un truc juste je
peux dire un truc il faut que tu il faut
que tu saches qu'il y a des gens qui
nous regardent certainement ils ont
trois enfants ils travaillent ils
rentrent le soir ils ont doivent faire
les devoirs des enfants ils doivent
faire les douches ils doivent faire les
trucs il y a souvent des familles
monoparentales aussi je peux te dire que
aujourd'hui la facilité aussi c'est
d'acheter des trucs tout près moi si
j'étais ministre
elle est super mais j'aurais dit plutôt
faites moins de profit on va baisser un
petit peu les profits et au lieu de dire
on va les cuisiner parce que quand tu as
une placer toute une journée à
travailler tu dois t'occuper des enfants
tu dois leur faire la douche et en plus
tu dois dire je dois aller faire les
courses pour cuisiner c'est impossible
donc c'est la facilité de prendre des
plats déjà tout préparé il faudrait
juste que voilà en ce moment tout le
monde fasse des efforts et que voilà les
les prix baisses et qu'on arrive on
arrête de vouloir aider tout le monde je
l'ai déjà dit la France on se prend pour
des tôliers et on est des tricards donc
voilà les gars excusez-moi je me suis
dit des choses voilà c'est vrai donc
voilà on se prend pour des tôliers et en
fait on a voilà c'est les mecs c'est le
mec qui va inviter tout le monde au
restaurant mais il a pas un franc sur
lui donc voilà donc c'est c'est bah
c'est ça bah c'est exactement on veut
aider tout le monde il y a même des gens
qui refuse notre aide non c'est bon
c'est bon on a pas besoin de vous voilà
le Maroc qui nous ont dit non non c'est
bon on vous emmerdez pas on a ce qu'il
faut non non mais c'est vrai j'ai vu une
vidéo un gars qui dit non mais
occupez-vous déjà de chez vous nous
inquiétez pas on a un roi qui s'occupe
très bien de nous vous inquiétez pas on
a plein de gens qui nous aident on n'a
pas besoin de vous restez chez vous ne
t'inquiète pas vous avez assez de merde
à faire chez vous déjà occupez-vous déjà
des gens qui travaillent et qui arrivent
pas à boucler la fin de mois qui arrive
pas à manger le 11 du mois plutôt de
vous occuper
non mais de vouloir faire les les
Justiciers partout dans le monde je vous
dis occupez-vous déjà des Français et de
ceux qui travaillent tous les jours de
8h à 19h et qui arrive pas à bouffer
voilà donc je suis Olivia Grégoire est
très sympathique et vraiment je l'aime
beaucoup et venu ici en plus je l'aime
bien Olivia mais là c'est pas se mettre
aussi à la place de famille qui n'ont
pas le temps et qui forcément à la
facilité c'est d'ouvrir des boîtes ou
d'ouvrir des trucs et ça coûte très cher
tiens c'est même pas sûr que ça coûte
plus cher en plus c'est pas sûr que
d'aller au marché de prendre des
produits
de pommes de terre c'est 1 € 70 tu
prends un sac de frites et entre deux et
6 euros on recevra Vico donne-moi le
droit de la pomme de terre il nous dira
ça lui